[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا فيكم برنامج بعد الصافره على
سي ان بالعربيه بعد مباراه كوريا
والبرازيل سالنا الجماهير عن وجهه نظرها
بالمباراه لشاهدت نتيجه عريضه جدا للمنتخب
البرازيلي خلال نسمع شكرا راي الجماهير
البرازيلي والجماهير الكوري مبسوطين اليوم
فوز البرازيل حلوه كانت المباراه
هنربح يعني بس همم اربعه جول يعني كثير
حلوين
في فرق اكيد مستويات البرازيل طبعا صنف
اولى عالميا
والكوريا الجنوبيه ممتازه على مستوى اسيا
وان شاء الله المستقبل لاسيا للامام يعني
اساسي اليابان قدمت كوريا الجنوبيه قدمت
السعوديه قدمت برضو يعني بطوله كبيره ان
شاء الله اسيا بالبطولات القادمه اكثر من
هيك فيديو
عوده
قوي جدا جدا والمنتخب
البرازيلي بالشوط الثاني قصه جهده وحاول
انه يحافظ بس على النتيجه وانه ما يتلقى
اهداف اضافيه لانه كان في اتفاق على عدم
زياده الغله لحتى اللاعبين ما يكون في
عليهم مجهود بدني اضافي قبل مباراه ربع
النهائي امام المنتخب الكرواتي حتى انه
تاتي مدرب البرازيل اجرى شويه تبديلات كان
من ضمن تبديل اليسون ودخول ويفرتون حارس
بالميراس لحتى يعطيه فرصه المشاركه بكاس
العالم لاول مره وربما هتكون فرصه الوحيده
لانه يشارك بالمونديال خلينا اعطيكم بعض
الارقام التاريخيه عن هذه المباراه بما
انه على مستوى التحليل مباراه ما كان فيها
كثير كلام ينقال انها كانت مثل ما حكينا
وان سايد او من جانب واحد ولكن هذه اكبر
نتيجه للبرازيل في الادوار الاقصائيه من
عام 1998 البرازيل ما سجلت رباعيه بمرمى
اي فريق بالادوار الاقصائيه لكاس العالم
من مباراه تشيلي في كاس العالم في فرنسا
عام 1998 مثل المحاكينا يعني النتيجه
كبيره عريضه وليست نتيجه عاديه بالنسبه
للمنتخب البرازيلي معلومه الثانيه لازم
تعرفوها انه نيمار بتسجي الهدف امبارح من
ركله جزاء صار ثالث لاعب برازيلي في
التاريخ يسجل في ثلاث نسخ لكاس العالم بعد
بيليه وبعد رونالدو لازاريو دليمه وبذلك
دخل ايضا كتب التاريخ في هدفه اللي سجله
بمرمى كوريا امبارح اما باحصائيه سلبيه
للمنتخب الكوري فكوريا الجنوبيه خسرت سبع
مباريات لعبتها ضد فرق امريكا الجنوبيه في
كؤوس العالم وبالتالي احصائيه سلبيه جدا
للمنتخب اسياوي لاعبوه المنتخب البرازيل
تعرضوا لبعض الانتقادات امبارح بسبب موضوع
الرقص المبالغه في بعض كل الهدف وكان راي
بعض انه ما بيصير انك ترقص بعد كل هدف لان
هذا الشيء في تقليل من احترام الخصم همم
ممكن بعد الهدف الاول يكون احتفال شويه
كبير ولكن بعد ذلك خلاص امور صارت طبيعيه
والمباراه ماشي
هذا اسلوب احتفال ما في اي مشكله نهائيا
ما في اي تقرير من الخصم ما في اي نوع من
من عدم تقدير نهائيا هي رخصه شهيره
بالبرازيل هي الرقصه الشعبيه عندهم
ولعب بحق له انه يحتفل باي هدف باي طريقه
كانت بدون ما يهين الخصم وبدون ما يوجه له
اي اهانه هل ستحقق البرازيل قبل كاس
العالم براي الشخص البرازيلي المرشح طبعا
فوق العاده وفرنسا لتحقيق اللقب بان اكثر
منتخبين اقنعه في هذه البطوله ولكن في
كؤوس العالم لا يؤمن جانب لاي منتخب اخر
يواجه منتخبات كبيره فالامور كل مباراه
بمباراتها ويجب على الجمهور البرازيلي ان
يتحلى بالعقلانيه حتى بعد هذا الفوز
العريض كوريا بعيدا عن دور 16 في كاس
العالم ومباراه البرازيل وكوريا رحنا
وسالنا الناس سؤال يتعلق بالدوله الغريب
للبرازيل وهي الارجنتين من الافضل ميسي ام
مارادونا خلينا نشوف شو جاوبوا ميسي ولا
مارادونا
همم بيرسوناليتي مارادونا اذا تتكلم عن
التالنت هو هو ميسي ولكن انا اللي يهمني
الاكثر من الموهبه بهمني اداره الامور
والسيطره على الامور اللي هو الكابيتانو
اي لايك
[موسيقى]
مارادونالدز
ميسي مارادونا ولا لاعب
في العالم
[موسيقى]